Okay.
What I did last time with describe to you a certain heat and didn't call the car
no engine.
So let me refresh your memory on what that was.
The whole engine consisted of a gas
without some pressure and some volume
and the gas was subject to a cycle
and the cycle went like this.
You start at some point a,
you expand at a certain temperature tea,
you want isothermally,
you come to the point B.
So the way you should imagine that is that this gas is placed on a reservoir.
Who's temperature is frozen?
I mean stuck that t one there's a worse,
never changed the temperature.
And what you do is you lift one grain after another of sand.
So you let the gas expand but you don't let it cool down the minute it tries to
call some,
he'll go from below,
they maintain the temperature and start at that volume and entered that volume.
During this process,
some amount of heat.
Q one enters the gas.
Next thing you do,
you let the gas expand some more,
but not you let it expand.
Ed diabetically.
Aerobatic means you put the whole thing in a heat insulating material so no heat
can go in a route.
Now you can see if it expands,
it's going to have to pay for it with its own internal energy.
So the temperature will drop.
So you wait until it drops to a lower temperature t two then you go backwards
like this.
That's when you start compressing the gas by putting some grains of sand back.
But this time the gas is kept in a lower temperature on top of the temperature
reservoir t two and you drop more sand on it to compress it.
There is this part
during this portion,
heat will actually be rejected by the gas.
Why is he rejected?
Because normally when you compress the gas,
you're doing work on it.
The energy should go up,
the energy goes up,
the temperature should go up,
but you're not letting the temperature go up.
You're forcing it to have the temperature t too.
So it'll reject heat into this heat pack.
And finally you come back to starting point by further compression.
But Idea Batek and antibiotic means it's insulated from the outside world.
No heat flow,
so there are four parts to things you have to notice about the car.
No engine.
In fact,
let me draw a schematic of the cardinal ended.
This is the standard where people draw that the engine takes some heat
from the furnace or t one it has some cure to rejected at the exhaust,
which is a t two added delivers certain Armando work with by the law of
conservation of energy.
I have to be Q one minus Q two
do you understand that the work then by the gas is equal to that and who paid
for it?
If the reservoir upper as a wire furnished the heat,
some heat was rejected downstairs at the difference between the two is the work?
No,
we call this a cyclic process because at the end of the day the gas has come
back to edit this.
That's very important.
If you want to make an engine,
it's not enough to convert.
The whole purpose of heat engines was to burn something and get some work out of
it,
but you don't want it to be a one shot thing.
You want to be able to do it over and over and over again and you can do that
with this engine because after the cycle it's back to where it started and you
can do this any number of times.
Now we define an efficiency for the same engine,
which is what you get divided by what you pay for,
what you get from the dentist.
Of course,
the work w and what you pay for is a call that you burn,
which is do you want no writing ws Cuban minus Q two you can write this as one
minus Q two over Q one.
This is true for any engine,
any engine,
even if it's not a car,
new engine,
uh,
by the law of conservation of energy,
you can write something like this anyway,
let,
let me say for the car,
the engine,
I got this as the efficiency.
Now why is the efficiency not 100% that's because Q two is not zero.
You can say,
why aren't we building a stupid engine that rejects him heat?
Why not just use all of it in some other fashion?
And that's what we're going to talk about,
but assuming that the engine operates between two temperatures,
the furnace temperature and the ambient atmospheric temperature,
you can calculate the efficiency for this engine by actually calculating youtube
and Q one.
That's the simple problem of integrating the work done in going from here to
here.
Do you remember that one minus n r
t one log VB over to be a and downstairs you have an r d to Log VC over vd.
Again,
you got to remember why that is true.
When you go from a to B,
there is no change in internal energy because the temperature is the same.
Therefore the work done and the heat input or equal numerically.
So Q two is the work done in Q one as the worked on there.
So that's what I got.
Then I did a little bit of calculation to show you by using the fact that B c
out of idea Batek curb a and D or an antibody curve,
that these logs actually canceled.
These guys of course cancel to give the final result,
one minus t two over t one that's the bottom line.
Uh,
I don't care what else you remember,
but this is something I need for today's discussion.
Efficiency of the car.
No engine is one minus p over t one.
Okay?
Now you can say why I'd be interested in this very primitive engine containing a
cylinder and gas and so on.
Uh,
okay.
This is the efficiency of the stupid engine.
I'm sure people can build a better engine,
so hit his car noise clean.
Mister Carlos says,
no engine
can be at my engine.
Okay?
That's this claim
by beat my engine.
He means no engine can be more efficient than my engine
and he's going to demonstrate that.
I'm going to demonstrate that for you.
You don't get something for nothing.
It's based on the following postulate with a told you last time.
I'm just going to write it.
I will repeat it.
We had been apostolate as the second law of thermodynamics.
That is impossible.
Define a process.
The sole result of which is the transfer,
some heat from a cold body to hot body.
We all know you can transfer heat from a cold body to hot body in a
refrigerator.
You take heat out of the freezer and dump it into the room.
No one says that's wrong,
but that's not the sole effect because you get an electric bill at the end of
the month because it's a compressive doing a lot of work.
The claim is not no other agency in the end.
Should it be affected in any fashion?
You find the end of the day,
all you had was heat flow uphill.
That's not allowed.
That's a postulate.
You have to grant them that postulate,
which we accept to be phenomenologically valley,
but taking that postulate,
cardinal will not show you that.
No Indian can beat his engine.
The key to the whole car,
no engine is that it is a reversible agent.
Waited versable engine.
I mean at every step in the car and the cycle.
Let's say going from here to here,
I can also go backwards.
I can put a grain of sand and compress the piston or I can take a grain of sand.
It'll go back to where it was.
You'd never far from equilibrium.
And if you can go one way you can go the other way.
That also means the car,
no engine starting at the point a can go backwards to d then to see then to be,
and then two a is the cardinal engine went backwards.
It will look like this.
It will take heed Q one,
sorry.
It'll take heat.
Cute too.
Somebody will give it where and will reject you won at this temperature.
This is the car,
no refrigerator
and that's the car,
no engine,
the cardinal in general refrigerator at the same machine.
We just can make it run one way or the opposite way.
That's what we are going to use.
So let me give you a demonstration a that's for as far as I can tell,
it's good enough for our present purpose that you cannot beat cardinal engine.
So let us say a car,
no engine,
take some heat.
Say 100 calories deliverance,
20 calories and work for the next 80 calories is operating between some two
temperatures.
Do you want an t two this is the car.
No,
I'm taking a particular example where the efficiencies what a one fifth
but don't worry about the fact that uh,
yeah,
so it's one fifth so one minus t two over t one should be one field.
Now if you say you have a better engine,
you have a better efficiency.
What you really mean is that your engine can take a hundred calories and deliver
more than 20 calories.
Maybe it'll deliver 40 calories and reject only 60 calories when it's also
operating between the same two temperatures.
This is your engine.
You for no why for your engine.
Okay,
you an engine is better than Carlos engine.
That's your claim.
You're not going to get shot down.
So how am I going to shoot this down?
I'm going to run the car,
no engine backwards.
First thing
that I'm going to get a card,
no engine,
which is twice as big as this car.
No Indian,
it's not more efficient.
We just got twice as much gas.
If you take a car,
no engine,
do the following things,
run it backwards and make it twice as big.
What will that cardinal engine do?
It will look like this.
It will take up 160 calories from downstairs.
It will want 40 calories input and it'll dump 200 calories upstairs.
So this is a two times car now a little bit,
put a start saying it's cardinal run backwards.
See,
it doesn't take any special genius to make an engine bigger.
It won't be more efficient.
It'll be have the same efficiency.
But if we can build something with one piston,
I can make the same design with the bigger piston or smaller piston.
I'm just saying I wanted it to be twice as big for the following simple reason.
Your Indians giving out 40 units of work.
Mine refrigerated needs 40 to run.
So what we do is we directly take the output from your engine and feed it to my
refrigerator.
Yeah.
Okay.
Your heating and didn't mix work.
My referee debris,
refrigerator needs work and I've scaled mine so that it's appetite matters.
Europe.
That's all I've done.
Now let's drop box around.
These guys.
Don't look under the hood and see what you've got
at the end of a full cycle,
when everything is done,
all the gases,
all the Pistons,
everything has come back to where it starts.
But no need to plug this gadget into the wall.
You don't have to plug this into anything because this refrigerator's getting
the power from this heat engine.
It doesn't need external power.
I look at the lower reservoir.
I see a hundred calories leaving.
You see that 60 coming down in one 60 going up.
I look at the upper cat reservoir.
I see 200 calories out in and 100 out.
So basically the combined gadgets,
yours and mine are equally,
this get
simply transfers heat from a core body to hot body with no other changes
anywhere in the universe that is not allowed
that for you cannot have an engine more efficient than the car new engine.
The logic is pretty simple.
These numbers,
they picked a representative,
but you can take any number as long as your engine that's better than mine
instead of 40 candidates.
But may 30 calories needed.
If it produced 30 I'll get an engine,
which is one and a half times as bigger than the standard engine.
Run it backwards.
You're 30 will feed my immediate Mangan and you will find,
once again,
heat is flowing from a call buddy to hot body with no other changes anywhere in
the universe that is forbidden by the postulate.
So this is how Carneros engine,
even though it's a very primitive engine,
is a standard for all Indians.
No engine can be better than the carnival.
And the key to the car new engine is that it's a reversible engine.
He's had more time.
I can show you that all reversible Indians operate in between two temperatures
will have the same efficiency,
namely that other car,
no engine.
Okay.
Now
what has the car new engine got to do with what I started saying earlier?
You remember I started saying earlier that a certain things,
and I would world that seem allowed but don't seem to happen.
Like you know,
drop an egg.
It doesn't come back in your hand.
You let the weight go down and turn the paddle the paddle.
He doesn't turn backwards and lift the weight.
I said many things are forbidden and that is a lot that's going to fall,
but all of them,
so I'm coming to that law,
but it all started with a person asking you very practical question,
how good can I make an entrance?
And what carbon is telling you is the best efficiency any Indian can have?
Is this that foot even today,
hundreds of years after car?
No.
No company in America or China anywhere can build an internal combustion engine,
for example,
who is efficiencies but better than this one?
It's a theoretical maximum.
In reality,
efficiency will be less than this because more than Indians have a loss that is
heat leaking out.
That is friction,
that's good for nothing.
So in the end the efficiency will be always lower than this.
Okay.
Now let me leave the practical domain and go to more theoretical issues that
follow from this.
What I want you to notice is the following for the cardinal engine Q one over Q
two turned out to be t one over t two right?
I did that for you here.
Therefore I'm going to write it as follows.
Q one over t one minus Q two over t two equals zero
that just a simple rewrite but I'm going to write this in another rotation,
my cycle at Fort Parts.
Remember I did this,
then I did this,
then I did this.
Then I did that
in the segment I had Q one over t one in this segment that was no Q one or Q two
there was no cute because this is the idea of biotic process.
In this segment I had minus you do over Q two and the last segment I had zero
and the whole thing is you.
In other words,
what I'm telling you is the following
at every stage,
if you look at the heat absorbed by the system in stage I divided by the
temperature of stage I and you added all of them,
you get zero.
My process at four stages,
stage one is here,
stage Drew's adiabatic states.
Three is this and stage four is zero.
Again,
in this summation,
QY is defined to be doctor Qy is the heat input
in state.
I in the cycle are in the process.
So we defined Q two to be positive even though it was rejected by the engine.
But in this summation,
the agreement I make is Delta Q is positive,
but if he comes into the system,
they'll tie cues negative.
He leaves the system.
So why is that important?
Now this is the heart of the whole entropy concert.
Remember I told you there is nothing called the heat in the system.
You cannot look at a gas and say that's the amount of heat in the system.
Why?
Because
if you take a point there and say that someone would have heat in the system,
if you go through some kind of cycle and come back to the same point,
then since you come back to the same point,
internal energy doesn't change.
This is the work done that for the work done is equal to the heat and there's
not zero.
So in this example,
what sort of happened is you'd ever had at added heat,
cute at the system.
So if there is some notion of how much heat is that in the beginning you've got
that.
Plus the cue that you added and yet you're back to where you are.
Therefore you cannot define something and that the amount of Q in the system
because you are able to add you to the system and bring it back to where it is.
What happened of course as you added Qid did some work.
But the point is you cannot say the cue here to so and so.
But you can say the energy here to so and so because he become back to the same
point.
P Times v is equal to three is equal to r t and the internal energy for gas.
That proportional duties they entered theater turns the old valley.
But now I'm going to tell you,
so listen very carefully.
Energy is a state variable because it comes to the starting value.
If you come to the starting point,
it doesn't matter where you want it off.
In the PV diagram,
he does not as state video.
There's nothing called the heat at that point.
Because I am able to go on a loop,
change the value of Cuba or add some cute to it and I come to the same point.
So there's no unique queue associated with that point.
But that is a new unique quantity s called entropy,
which has a fixed value at a given point.
And if you go fight the little loop in the PV diagram and you come to the same
point s we'll return to the starting value.
So who is this s that s is defined by saying the change in the entropy
is the heat you add divided by the temperature in a tiny little process.
If you had some temperature to you,
add a little amount of Q.
Okay,
keep track of all the changes
and that change will be zero as I showed you in this car,
no cycle.
You can show more generally that if you take any path,
not just the carton was cardinal engine bounded by Adiabatic and Eissa
tournaments,
but any path you take you can show that that Delta Q added up.
It's not zero,
but Delta Q over t namely weight.
The give a weighting factor one over t to the heat you add.
Then the positives and negatives cancel and give you exactly as you.
In other words,
Q one was not cute to Q one is bigger than cute too,
but Q one over t one precisely balanced the skew to over tee to the heat
absorbed at higher temperature if divided by t one to compute the change in
entropy.
Then in the upper part,
the carbon cycle here and the lower part of the carbon cycle here,
the two canceled as far as the entropy change is concerned,
so entropy is a new variable.
It's a mathematically discovered variable.
What we find is that if I postulate there's a variable called entropy.
The change in which in any process is the heat transfer divided by temperature.
Then that has the property that when you go around on a loop,
you come back to net zero change.
That means every point can be associated with the number.
You can call it entropy.
Entropy is like a height.
Suppose you're walking around on some landscape.
Each point is a height.
You can walk here and there and come back at at every stage you keep track of
the change in height.
If you come back to bed,
you are,
the change in height will add up to zero.
That's what I told you.
In the case of a potential energy function,
it is just like a potential energy function.
Internal Energy and the entropy are now state variables at every point.
The gasses are certainly internal energy and entropy.
The dessert because state variables,
because when you go on a loop and come back,
did return to the starting values.
No,
you have no idea what this quantity stands for.
You agree?
It's bizarre.
We're done.
We understand heat absorbed and he'd rejected.
We understand.
What is Delta Q over t y s divided by t makes a big difference.
Why does it produce a new variable?
We can see it as true.
At least in the current cycle.
You can verify in detail that that changed in the,
the total of all the Deltek use over t is in fact zero.
So we'll develop a feeling for what it means,
but historically this is what happened.
People realize,
hey,
that's another state video.
We introduced a new available,
we have no idea what it means,
but it is a state variable so we better take it very seriously.
So I'm going to tell you what it means,
but first I want you to get some practice calculating the entropy change for a
couple of processes.
So let us take for example,
one gram of water,
oh,
let's say am grams of some substance.
It's got some specific heats,
C
and I change the temperature,
say from some tea initial present.
The final.
I do that by keeping the system starting this system a t one t I and I should
never be far from equilibrium.
That's one of the conditions on this.
In fact,
you can say it should be near always near equilibrium.
So the system starts at temperature t initial,
I put it on a heat bath,
which is infinite decimally warmer than this than I let it heat up at that
point.
Then I put it on another reservoir,
slightly harder than this one at all stages.
I want the system to be almost near equilibrium in the sense of calculus.
You can make the difference as small as you like provider to do enough number of
times and slowly.
I raised this guy from here to here at every stage.
The system as a well defined temperature,
that's a bell defined heat input and I want to add it all up.
So what's the change in entropy as final minus initial is equal to DQ over t
summed over all the parts are actually right.
Listen,
integral as m c Delta t over tea.
Do you see that?
Dqs Mc,
Delta t but I got a divided by t and that's integral is done between some
initial and final temperature and when we can do this integral,
the trivially Mc log,
the final over t initial,
that is the increase in entropy of some m grams or some substance,
a specific EFC that's heated from t initial to the final.
Okay.
We just getting practice calculating this.
We still don't know what this guy means,
so don't worry about that right now.
If you did not divide by t,
what are they calculating?
Mc Delta t integrated.
It's just MC at times change in temperature.
That's the old calorie metric problem you did.
How many calories does it take to raise the substance from some initial to final
temperature that you understand when you divide by teas and think you don't
understand.
But anyway,
let's make sure we know how to calculate the increase in entropy when water or
something is heated from a lower to a higher temperature.
Yeah,
if you called it from a higher to lower temperature,
you can use the same formula Tfo Rti,
but TFL now is smaller than Tei if you called it.
It's a log of a number.
Less than one is negative and the entropy change,
it'll be negative.
So let me do one more entropy calculation.
That's going to be pretty important for us.
That entropy calculation is this.
Take a gas
and watch it expand.
I used to terminally from some starting point
at some fixed temperature t it goes from v one two V two
what is the change in entropy when it goes from here to here?
Again,
the system must always be in equilibrium or near equilibrium,
so I can plot it as a point in the PB diagram.
So I slowly take green after green to the whole thing I told you and find s two
minus x one this is two and this is one that is equal to sum of all the heat
transfers divided by temperature at every little step of the way.
But remember this is also the same as p Delta v over t.
Why?
Because on an isothermal the U is zero.
I've repeated it many times,
but you got to know this Delta Qsp Delta p but p over t is an r t over be heavy.
You also want to divided by t.
You understand p over t is an Rov,
so p is equal NRT over.
I'm just saying PBS NRT.
So p over t is an auto would be now DV over B.
When you somebody integrate,
we'll give you an R log B two over the B one.
That is a change in entropy of this gas.
When it went from Walden v one the Malian be two at a given temperature.
You don't have to use calculus to do this.
They said everybody understand why this could've been done a lot easier.
You don't need to do the integral here.
Yeah,
because I showed you in studying the heat engine that the heat transfer queue is
n r t allowed me to over be one.
Since the whole process takes place at fixed temperature instead of dividing by
t at every step.
You can just divide by t overall.
Yes.
Bring the tea here.
That's why this is the tendon entropy.
Other words during the whole process you failed at one temperature than integral
of Delta Q over t is just one over two times the integral of Delta Q which is
the total heat transfer.
Anyway,
this is the heat this at the tangent entropy s two minus s one yes,
and our Lord me too.
Over v one
okay,
so what have I done so far?
That's a collectible.
Our thoughts here.
I went to the car,
no engine today
and reminder,
do what efficiency the cardinal engine was.
Then I showed,
you know Indian can be better than the car,
no engine.
That's a separate story that has to do with how efficient things can be.
Then a byproduct with the cardinal engine was this great realization that if you
go on a close loop and an everybody stayed,
you add,
you compute the heat absorb but divide by the temperature.
At that point,
the summer fall dose is zero.
What that means is that that is a quantity s who's change if it is defined to be
delta Q over t has the property.
That shortage changed in as zero.
When you go around the loop,
that means at every point they can associate an s s is a property of the point
now that exit,
so then,
then I said let's get used to computing change in I two one example of heating a
substance of some mass in specific EFC by a temporary bt and the change in
entropy was Mc log,
d f over t I you got the lock because integral of Dt over t was logarithm.
Then I took an ideal gas.
I let it expand isothermally I found the entropy change.
I got this answer.
By the way,
here's an interesting exercise.
I don't have time to do it,
but you can ask the following question.
If you tell me that every point that's unique entropy.
The entropy difference between two and one should be independent of how I go
from one to two.
You understand good walking on a mountain,
you take two points,
they have a high difference and I can find the height difference by going on
this path,
keeping track of the change in height or any other path.
In the end,
the height difference between two points is a high difference.
So I could find the entropy another way.
Let me show you another way that is easy for you guys to work out.
Come down like this and go to the right like this and find the entropy change.
You will get the same answer.
I say God on this site.
Okay?
It's too tempting for me to just leave it to you.
Let me tell you how it works.
Call this intermediate point.
Um,
give a subsequent Bazuto footballers parameters.
Then in this step,
when you come from here to here,
the entropy change will be,
let's take one more for gas.
When I go from here to here.
Then for one mole of a gas,
this heat transferred Dq is see CVD t and a divided by t and I do the integral
from t one for this point.
[inaudible].
That's the entropy change here.
Then in the horizontal part,
since I'm going at constant pressure,
I go CP three over tea from tea,
not up to back to [inaudible] because this t one and t two are the same
temperature.
I have to add all these to get the entropy change.
No,
it's a two step process.
You come down because you're a constant volume and they're doing something to
the gas DQ.
CVD t.
How does [inaudible] at constant pressure DQC PDT,
the definition of specific either Austin volume of constant pressure,
but notice the following c p is equal to c plus R
so put CV plus out here and look what you get.
Then you get CV famous log t not over.
T one plus log,
a t one over t knock,
which we can write this product here
plus our log p one over Tina.
In other words,
this log is log of tea.
Not over t one.
The next is log of t one over t log a plus log B is log of Ab,
but when you do this,
look what happens here.
This on cancel log of one to zero the total entropy change is our log t one over
t not
but for the gas,
that constant pressure
using PV equals Rt.
This ratio of temperature is also the ratio of the volumes.
So this one,
I'm sorry,
I should write it more carefully.
Then I say t one I really meant the temperature at this point.
Second Point.
So that temperature or this temperature is also that volume.
The better the initial volume,
which is v one
see this is a confusing problem because Steve one happens to be ti not the
correct way to do this for me would be the right tea,
not over t one time t two over tea.
Not then realize the fact that a t two and t one are equal because I'm on a
nicer term.
That's what I should've done.
So I should cancel this factor because d two is one,
but here t two over teen art is B two over Overby not which is B two over v one
that's of course the entropy change.
They got in one shot here.
So you can find entropy change anyway you like.
You usually pick the easiest path.
All right,
so we have now learned how to find entropy change.
We have no idea what it means.
It seems as if when you hit something,
entropy goes up,
when you call something entropy goes down.
That's certainly correct because Delta Q is positive,
but heating and divided by t.
You may get a logarithm,
but we're not.
Every infant of the small portion,
I'm adding positive numbers and then they cooled things that goes down.
Why not just call it temperature?
Why do you need this new concept called entropy?
So that's what the rest of the lectures about.
It's a very,
very powerful and beautiful concepts.
I want to explain that makes sure I get it right
here is now the reason for all this hard work.
Remember I told you that are many,
many,
many phenomena that seemed forbidden in our world and we're not quite sure what
law to invoke to prevent all of them from happening to be one of the law for
each one that says if you drop a bottle and the shatters,
it won't come back.
If can drop an egg,
If you let hot and cold mix,
they're not going to unmixed or if you let a gas trapped in half a room escape
of the whole room,
it'll never untrapped and go back to half the room.
A lot of things happen one way but not the other and I said,
I'm looking for a mega law that will prevent all these things from happening.
Now I'm ready to state that law.
This is the third law I the second law of thermodynamics.
Carnot said it one way,
but I'm going to say it in a way that's very,
very general.
The second law of thermodynamics says Delta s four the universe is a that zero
or positive.
Yeah,
you have it.
That's the great law.
The law says take any process.
If at the end of the process,
the entropy of the universe is bigger than it was before,
that will happen.
If the entropy of the universe is smaller than it was before,
it will not happen.
No.
We have to make sure that this lies anything whatsoever to do with all the other
things we have studied and I will show you this one forbit everything that
should be forbidden and allow everything that should be alone.
So let me start with the most obvious formulation.
Mr. Car version of the second law was that you cannot have a process in which
some heat cue goes from a hot body to call buddy.
I'm sorry,
this is a loud right.
I caught in the car.
No,
this is not a low
right.
He can flow downhill,
cannot flow uphill.
Let's see the entropy change the universe for the two cases.
In this case,
this guy,
the change in entropy is the following.
The upper reservoir lost some on cue.
So Delta you as a negative number.
I have some temperature t one the lower reservoir gain queue at temperature t
too.
No.
What's the overall sign of this?
Think about it.
T wants bigger than t two so this negative number,
the smarter than this positive number.
So the whole thing is positive.
That means it's alone.
It's okay.
Wait,
the same token,
if you take this process when heat flows uphill,
then this reservoir,
losing some heat cube,
I can put the t two other one gains heat.
You are temporary,
the t one,
but this is clearly less than zero because this positive number is smaller than
this negative number.
So that you have a very simple example where if heat flows the wrong way,
the entropy of the universe goes up
and it's very simple.
It's only it's because it is the heat loss of this guy is the heat gain of that
guy.
That's the law of conservation of energy.
So energy doesn't change,
but entropy changes because for entropy,
it's not the heat transfer t transfer divided by temperature that for a heat
lost,
but one temperature and the heat gained at a lower temperature don't cancel when
it comes to entropy.
In one case,
the entropy goes up and read aloud.
Another case entropy goes down.
It's not low.
Okay,
so let's try.
So that's certainly one prices that you know should not be allowed.
But it's forbidden by the third law,
by a computation of intro.
So the reason when you put a hot and cold body together,
heat flows from the cold to the hot,
I'm sorry,
from the hot to the cold is because that's the way the entropy will go up.
So let's take one more example.
Supposed to have
some mass of water at some temperature t one and an equal mass of water at
temperature t two
one is hard from one is called.
I put them together.
What will happen,
we believe it will then get this big mass.
All are some common temperature.
The star,
which is t one plus t two over to this is just by symmetry is equal mass equals
specific heat.
Where will they meet?
They will meet halfway.
They will meet here.
Energies of course conserved and that Soviet determined in fact where they will
meet.
We'll look at the entropy.
What happens?
The entropy change for the entropy change.
You should imagine this water being steadily heated by putting it in contact
with a lot of reservoirs,
search never far from equilibrium and slowly bringing it to this point.
Then the Delta s total will be m specifically this one.
Then Delta p over t starting from t one to t star for one thing and the p over t
from t two to t star.
The other one you understand that they're both made a t star.
Upper limit is the star lower one is t one for one and t two for the other.
So the change in entropy becomes m log.
These star square over t one t two
no.
We have to ask.
Okay,
you got an entropy change from start to finish,
but how do you know it's positive?
Did anybody give some reason why this has to be positive with our looking into
properties of logarithms and so on?
Any reason what?
Yes,
that should be
greater than.
Yeah.
So that's one way to prove that,
but I'm saying I'm going to prove it to you that way,
but can you think of a reason why at every step of the process,
when I brought this down and when I pushed that up,
the entropy change is always positive.
We need steps.
So let me explain.
Imagine cooling this down a little bit by putting,
taking some heat.
They'll take you out of this guy that's happening or sometimes some temperature
here.
This one is gaining some delta Q but at a lower temperature.
Okay?
Therefore,
the gain
has got the same Delta Cuba at a lower temperature.
This is always at an upper temperature throughout the process.
At every stage,
this guy is harder than this guy,
so every calorie of heated gains at a higher temperature.
Every calorie loses is divided by higher temperature.
Every calorie,
this gains so divided,
but lower temperature at every increment.
At every infant small step,
you can see the total entropy change is possible.
Now to prove it,
we will do what he just said.
If you want to prove this as positive,
you want to show that the fellow inside the logarithm is bigger than one.
So I'm asking is t one plus t two square over for bigger than t one t two
what I'm saying is Steven Steve to squared bigger than 41 t two if you rearrange
this,
you can show the lefthand side becomes t one minus t two square.
That's of course a positive number because this should be [inaudible] squared
plus [inaudible] squared plus plus two t one t two and when I bring this guy to
the other side will become minus two t one t two and so it's clearly positive.
So when Hart and called meat and reach Luke warm entropy of the universe has
Ghana,
it follows.
Therefore,
if Luke warm spontaneously separated in a hot and cold,
the entropy would go down and that's why that doesn't happen.
That's why if you leave a jar of water at one temperature,
it doesn't spontaneously separate into a part on top,
which is called an a part on bottom because hard set,
the separation would not violate anything.
Okay?
It would not violate the law of conservation of energy,
but it will violate the law that entropy has to always go up.
So one way is allowed in other ways not allowed.
So you see over and over again that anything that's allowed isn't the direction
of increasing entropy.
Anything that's forbidden isn't the direction of decreasing entropy.
But who is this entropy?
What does it mean?
Well that we have not understood at all from any of these calculations because
DQ over tea doesn't speak to us the way the you or Dq or PDV does.
So the last part of what I'm going to do is going to explain to you
what is the microscopic basis of entropy.
Why is the entropy going up connect?
Why is that?
Why did we understand the tendency of things to go into that extra of increasing
entropy?
All I've shown you now is that that is mystical quantity called entropy.
Circumstantially,
you find every time something is forbidden is because had it taken place,
entropy would have gone down.
You remember the heat flow in from hot to cold entropy goes up,
allowed Ryan from cold to hot.
Entropy goes down,
not alone,
hot and cold mix and become lukewarm.
Allowed.
Entropy goes up,
lukewarm separates in the hot and cold,
not allowed.
Entropy goes down.
So there's definitely a correlation and yet we don't know what it means.
So we're going to talk about what it means for that.
I'm going to consider the following process.
I take a gas and I put it in a room in a box where there's a partition or
halfway,
the molecules are stuck in the left side.
Gas reached equilibrium and it's done what it can,
which is to spread out over this volume.
Now I suddenly removed the partition,
rip it up.
So let's follow this gas initially is the point here.
Mm.
Then that is a pdf when it goes off the radar,
because I told you when you suddenly removed the wall,
the gas is not in a state of equilibrium.
It doesn't even have a well defined pressure.
The minute to room with a walk pressure,
there's something here.
Pressure the zero in the vacuum here.
So you've got to wait a bit.
So gas has gone off the radar.
We cannot talk about what's happening.
Then if you wait long enough,
I get a gas that looks like this after some seconds or whatever milliseconds
that is again,
gas in equilibrium.
It's got a certain state.
I can call it
two.
What is the entropy change now?
That's what I want to ask.
What the change in entropy here,
because I know that this is allowed.
That is forbidden.
So I want to ask,
did the entropy go up?
Now how do we do the entropy calculation?
Here is a wrong way to do the calculation.
You go back and say delta is a Delta Q over tea,
but this whole box,
I forgot to mention,
I'm sorry,
it's four boxes thermally isolated.
It's not in contact with anything.
I just ripped out the partition in the middle.
That's it.
So you might say ability for thermally isolated Delta Q is zero.
So you can divide by tea.
You can do what you want.
So this entropy change zero.
But that is the wrong argument.
Can you think about why that's not the way to do the entropy?
Change the way that's the wrong
analysis.
First of all,
could that be the right answer?
Yes.
Going backwards?
Uh,
no,
that is correct.
But I'm saying this computation of entropy,
the one line calculation I did,
namely there is no heat in flow.
The delta Q is zero.
So delta Q over t summed up his answer zero.
That's not how you do the entropy change.
Does that add any condition I made on computing?
Yes.
He goes the gas.
Uh wait.
In fact here is the interesting thing.
What's going to be the temperature difference between before and after,
which is going to be hotter or cooler.
Any views on this?
Yep.
You guys added,
ah,
well
you can say it is cooler because it was insulated and expanded,
but you cooled down because he expand against an external pressure.
Right?
Even my natal more this piston here,
that is not pressure pushing this gas back.
You understand that it doesn't do any work.
It doesn't take any heat.
So what does that mean in the end when you settle down,
what can you conclude then?
No heat input,
no work done.
So what does that mean in terms of temperature?
Same.
Because the internal energy cannot change.
The delta you with zero work done is zero.
So in fact,
this is a bright,
this gas when an expanse will be at the same temperature or you guys are taking
up the computer,
Eh,
where if you let it expand at Coldstone because that is expanding against the
atmospheric pressure.
This gas is expanding into a complete vacuum.
It's gotten no piston to push.
Again,
nothing from outside pushing.
So these two points are at the same temperature.
So the correct answer maybe you didn't catch on,
but I will tell you the correct answer is that isn't an entropy increase in this
problem because the final state definitely has a well defined entropy.
You can calculate because it's an equilibrium state.
Initial Monessen bell define entropy in between stages.
Here are not on the PV diagram because they have not equilibrium states.
So in this experiment,
the way to calculate the entropy change is not to do delta Q over.
T acid happened in this experiment.
What you really want to say is my gas was he at in the beginning?
My guess is that in the end,
both that states of equilibrium both have well defined temperature and I can
find the entropy change in going from here to here,
but any process I want
as long as that process keeps the system near equilibrium.
Second follow dot bye dot [inaudible] and moving and I had the delta Q over t
the correct route for entropy changes is Delta Q over t computed on a path than
with the system.
Never strays from me.
Paypal,
liberty,
no your system straight from equilibrium all the time but we are not interested
in habit.
Got from here to here we are saying what's the entropy here and watch the
entropy here since it's at the same temperature.
I know one way to go from there to there is to follow the ice up there because
that is connected to points in this particular problem.
Then I know the entropy change just as two minus one is an our log
be too over before.
So here's the sub bullet point I want to explain to you.
This is worth understanding.
A lot of people do all the problems and get everything right but don't
appreciate this particular question.
The three expansion of a gas into the vacuum takes it from one equilibrium state
called one another equilibrium state called to
in the actual expansion,
the system went through state which cannot be one shown in the PB diagram.
They were not equilibrium states that didn't have a defined pressure,
didn't have well defined temperature.
How do you define a temperature when half the boxes empty?
It doesn't have,
you cannot call it the temperature of the gas.
So what do you mean by Delta Q over tea there is no t only when her set it's
down,
there is a t every settled down equilibrium state as well defined entropy.
What we're trying to do is to compute the difference.
The way to compute the difference is to forget about what actually happened and
instead do the following.
Take the gas
like that and turn it this way if you like,
just for convenience for the Piston are at the halfway point,
put some weights on it.
So the depression equals depression inside
and slowly remove little by little and keeping it on a reservoir.
Our temperature t one,
which is the temperature at which all of this happened,
or at some temperature t
as you remove the grain of sand,
what happens is the gas gets some energy.
That's a delta Q over t.
The reservoir loses some heat.
In fact,
the reservoir loses is the same or what the,
he built a queue at the same temperature t.
So in fact,
what happens in this process is the entropy of the universe does not change at
all.
The entropy gain of the gas is entropy,
loss of the reservoir,
but I use this as a device for finding the entropy gain of the gas in the other
process.
So this is the part that's absolutely central to this whole argument.
Oh,
entropy's is calculated in a real spontaneous expansion of a gas,
but there was no orders or wild,
no nothing.
We just broke the partition and expanded.
That is a change in entropy.
That's an irreversible process,
but to find the change in entropy in this problem since one and two have well
defined entropy's we can find the between one and two by going to a different
experiments in which it was brought from one to two not in this crazy
irreversible way but by putting it contact with the heat bath at that
temperature t removing grain after green,
never straying far from equilibrium.
That's when we find this change.
So you replace the dotted line where you cannot compute anything by a solid line
where you can but since the change in entropy between one and two that doesn't
depend on how you got there.
That's the answer.
But this process,
right,
you can actually see it is a one in with Delta s of the Universe is actually a
zero.
Why?
Because you're putting in contact with the reservoir at the same temperature.
So the Delta Q over tea for the gas and Delta Q Q over top of the reservoir.
Exactly cancel because they are at the same temperature in Delta Q four one is
minus,
they'll take you for the other,
so don't confuse the two processes.
One is a reversible process in which the gas is slowly allowed to expand from
the initial state of the final state by removing grain after the brain off.
Some externally applied pressure in a process where the attribute university
doesn't change gas and reservoir change by equal amounts,
but the punchline is I don't care what happens reservoir,
I want to know how much the gas gained because that is the gain I need defined
as two minus s one for this process.
Yeah,
so this will be always financial between in real life processes happen in a way
in which the entropy of the universe goes up.
Because take this box in the real experiment.
Remember that [inaudible] there's only the box of gas.
It expanded.
Its entropy went up,
so entropy of the universe actually went up.
That's waves.
Hello.
The attribute,
the university went up by an amount equal to the increase in entropy of the gas
when it goes from one to two defined the increase in entropy of the gas.
When it goes from one to two I create a second process in which I can compute
the change by letting it go in a sequence of connected dots and finding the
change.
The way you used to find the change in entropy is not the way the entropy
increase took place in the real process.
So I don't think I wanted to beat at any more,
but it's an important point and you should really think about that.
All right.
Now
the last point is
what?
This,
let's analyze this final formula.
I got what?
Entropy change for three expansion of gas.
Let's take a simple case where the gas expanded from some volume,
the bill volume two Times v.
What does Esther minus s one s two minus s one is n.
Our log to do happens to be the two over one.
The volume has doubled.
Let me rewrite this as and k blog too
because number of side as and number of molecules name's Kay.
Let me rewrite that as a log of two to the n Times k.
Now I will tell you what all these factors mean
and that comes from the following dumper dynamics only told you the formula for
the change in the entropy of for guests didn't tell you what the entropy itself
is.
So the formula for the entropy of a gas without talking about the change and
also this formula delta.
So delta Q over t doesn't even believe in atoms.
You don't need atoms,
you don't need molecules.
You don't need to know what anything is made apart.
In fact,
it was discovered long before Adam's for proven to exist.
Boltzmann is the guy who gave the formula for what the entropy of a gas is in
terms of what the individual molecules are doing.
That's the punchline of what's called statistical mechanics,
which gives you the microscopic origin of thermodynamics.
Thermodynamics to this stage talked about fluids and solids and gases and
nothing there requires that everything we made up of atoms,
you don't have to know what it's made of.
But if you're telling me it's made up or Madams,
you have a better idea what entropy means.
And here is Boltzmann formula for entropy.
I'm going to write it down.
Boltzmann constant times log omega.
I'll tell you what omega is in a minute.
This such an important formula.
It is written in Boltzmann's tombstone.
So when physicists go to Vienna,
we skip the archis,
Ra's and everything else.
We go to Boltzmann's tune and we read this formula once more with some passion
that the summary of a lifetime of work.
But it's a great formula and you will understand once you know the formula,
what all this means.
So let me tell you what Omega means.
I'm going to say in words,
then I'm going to apply to this problem.
If it took any gas,
let it be under certain conditions that macroscopically have some pressure and
some volume and so on.
So here is the guests at one instant.
Now we believe in atoms.
Here are these atoms scattered all over the place?
Suppose I wait a little bit.
What does the gas look like?
It looks like that
if you can see every atom,
the atomic configuration has changed,
but macroscopically nothing has changed.
Instead of atom a being here,
maybe a has gone and bs come here,
and particularly if it divided the volume,
it was some number of little cells that you can count on the average.
The gas has uniform density.
There's some number of atoms,
but every little pubic and formed a little later I more than somebody else moves
in macroscopic lead.
It looks the same to me.
Microscopically stuff is going on.
Omega.
Yes,
the number of different microscopic arrangements that agree with what is seen
macroscopically.
When I say microscopic arraignments,
I really mean the following.
Give every molecule in name a,
B,
c,
d,
whatever.
Then put a here and be here.
See here in d there.
That's one arrangement.
Then permute woody here and be here and see her hernia.
That does another idea to my naked eye.
They all look the same but they all produce the same macroscopic effect,
but there are different microscopic arrangements
and you were supposed to take the log of the number of the sediments multiply by
this constant called Boltzmann's constant to get the entropy of a state.
So now let's apply it to this gas here.
Okay.
No,
the number of microscopic arrangements if you really wanted to get down to it
requires dividing the box and the tiny little cells,
maybe one cubic millimeter and saying how many items?
I didn't need the region,
but we are going to do a crude calculation in which will only say the following
a that a molecule is on the left.
Artists on the right,
we are saying these are the only two positions open to the gas left or right.
Of course in the left that is a left card and the top left corner bottom.
But don't worry about,
just say that only two things you can do.
It can be on the left or it can be on the right.
Now let's ask ourselves if the gas looks like this.
Okay.
How many ways can it be in this setting
as compared to
how many ways can it be in this setting?
Okay.
It is like the following molecules are moving randomly given molecule has got 50
50 times of being on the left or being on the right.
You are demanding that all the and molecules on their own,
there's no partition now on their own,
the on the left hand side
you can see that it's like tossing a coin
and times and wanting heads every time because you want every guy you know,
random process to end up picking left.
So if you want them all to be left,
there's only one way to do that.
And that's like saying I tossed a million coins,
I wanted all heads.
There's only one way to do that
so that that engagement,
if you,
we will say,
looks like this left,
left,
left for everybody that's the end.
Had been here.
Take another one but one molecule,
it's all been here
and all the others that here on the left side that looks like left,
left,
right,
left.
But that's one arrangement.
But have I done my complete homework here at our Delmarva arrangements.
I want you to think about,
pardon me,
this is the only one of the,
I didn't meant for the molecule on the right.
That's another arrangement in which I can have the second molecule molecule more
Joe Arpaio,
whoever's here,
you can pick them in end waste already been one is on the left and minus one on
the right that are more ways in which that can happen.
So your ics one on the right end minus one on the left,
but that in ways in which that can happen,
it's like saying if I toss coins,
I want one head and 99 tails.
Well it turns out that are a hundred ways in which it can happen because the one
headache got,
could have occurred in one of the a hundred different terms.
Now suppose I want to heads and 98 tapes.
Then as you know,
the way to do that is 100 times 99 divided by one time too.
These are some common and Torics you learn in high school,
so you find that if you plot number of heads over the total number
and ask what,
how many ways in which that can happen.
All heads can I cut in only one way.
Every coin has to be head one had less.
One Taylor,
99 heads can occur in end ways,
then it will become more and more and more and you will find the 50 50 chance of
half the number of heads and have the number of tails has the biggest I couldn't
rate.
Okay,
because that's the most number of ways to get 50 50 than anything else and 100
heads is as bad as 100 tails.
Again,
there's only one way in which you can get all heads in one way in which you can
get all tails,
but as you start scrambling them that are more and more ways,
that means for the molecule,
you've got a hundred molecules.
The number of states Omega is the largest.
When did equally distributed in fact as the number of molecules scores from
hundred two thousand two million to 10 to the 23 this function is so sharply
peaked that the approximate formula for Omega when it's at the 50 50 thing is in
fact to the namely all the arrangements waterless belong to this configuration,
that 40 if you've got back to Boltzmann formula and like let me keep the formula
here and look at sc equals Keylogger Omega,
then you find
as one,
it's when everybody is on the left.
That is k log one
and s two is 50 50 mix,
half on the left and half on the right.
That entropy is Kellogg to the end.
Okay.
Therefore you can see that's what I wrote down here along to Dm.
So the way you understand entropy is the following.
If I give you a gas
and ask,
will they ever like to be in the left half of the box on their own?
Of course they won't,
but if you start them out that way,
you forced them to be on the left.
They'll be on the left.
Question is,
if you remove the partition,
what would they likely do?
Unlike coins,
which once they land on their head,
they have to stay on the head.
These molecules can move around.
Question as if they were all left to begin with.
How long can that possibly last?
If they start moving randomly,
they will always end up doing this because there are many,
many more ways to do this than to do this,
so things go from one arrangement macroscopic to another,
one left to their own device because the final state can be realized and many,
many more ways than the initial state.
Similarly,
if you combine a hot gas and the coal gas,
this is hard.
This is called with a terminally insulating partition.
Then all the hearts are on the left.
All the calls are on the right.
If you remove the terminal installation or not even remove it,
replace it by heat conducting thing you went to lead.
The temperatures would equalize.
So what do you find every time is there's many,
many ways in which you can pack your items.
If you put all the heart on the left,
all the cold on the right,
that can be achieved in fewer ways than in which you let them all go wherever
they like.
So what do you find?
This entropy is a direct measure of how disordered your system is.
Yeah.
One technical measure of disorder is to ask how many microscopic arrangements
can lead to what I see and take the log of that number.
And what you find is this has a very low entropy.
This is a very high entropy because this configuration,
in other words,
if you took a gas in a whole room and ask will it ever go to this configuration,
that is a slight chance,
it will.
That chance is one part in to the end where they understand that the 23 so it's
not something you should wait for,
but it can happen.
So the second law of thermodynamics is a statistic,
a law
microscopically,
it's perfectly allowed for the gas too.
Suddenly all the guests,
the whole room can come to where I am.
That's allowed.
But you don't hold your breath because that's not likely to happen.
The art for that is again,
one part in one over to do some huge number.
On the other hand,
if in this part of the room we really,
some gas,
everybody quickly spread out because there are more ways to do it.
So we understand completely now why certain things occur and why they don't.
Because if you took a hot water and cold water,
you're separating them to fast molecules and slow molecules.
As long as they're in different insulated containers,
that's the best they can do.
But if you put them in contact so they no longer have to be separated,
question is will they remain separated?
It's like saying I have bunch of coins which are all left and all right,
but they're allowed to flip as a function of time,
but they'll never remained that way.
Okay,
so what happened is the coal molecules and heart will mingle and soon the
container will have cold everywhere and heart everywhere and you will get some
intermediate temperature.
Or if it took two different dyes,
you know,
water here on top of 54 some red paint,
there'll be initially separated after a while.
They will mix because there's no reason for the heart,
for the red molecules to stay on the top forever.
They would like to occupy the whole box and sober the colorless ones and
eventually it will become pink because there's more ways to remain pink than to
remain separated.
Likewise,
spink spontaneously separated into red and colorless.
Uh,
that is very,
very improbable because entropy for that state will be lower.
So you have to understand the second law of thermodynamics or saying certain
things occur because if you go in that direction,
you can realize that arrangement in more ways.
And since microscopic motion is random,
it's like tossing coins to ask for an heads.
When you toss and times,
it's like asking all the molecules to be on the left side of the room to ask for
50 50 heads and tails.
It's like asking for molecules to populate the room equally.
Yes,
that's called the Arrow of time,
but you've got to be careful about one thing.
The entropy of a part of the universe can go down just to the entropy of the
whole universe will not go down.
So all of life is an example of lowering entropy because you know the creation
of life or the creation of tomatoes out of mud is a highly organizing process.
So the entropy there is really going down,
but if you kept track of the rest of the world,
you will find that some corresponding increase of entropy somewhere else or take
your freezer.
You know your refrigerator's sucks heat out of your freezer.
Delta Q over tea for that is negative,
but somewhere there's bigger heat emitted outside from the exhaust new
refrigerator.
If it took care of all of that entropy of the universe will go up or remain
sane,
but it doesn't go down.
All right.
I have given you guys a three problems.
You should go on the website today.
Two of them should take about five minutes other than maybe 10 minutes.
I want you to think about calculating entropy changes.
That's part of this syllabus.
As part of our course.
It'll come on line today.
So I've asked for them to be do either on Friday or Monday.
I don't know which one,
whichever one marijuana,
but it's a 30 minute exercise.
I was,
I just,
you guys attack it when you go back.
Okay,
so this is it.
This the end of part one.
I'll see probably many of you when we do part two to look at the ENM and quantum
mechanics
[inaudible].